So let's look at just one more example.
We're going to be testing some sort of a graphical application.
So we have a GUI application that's our software under test.
And so we have to ask ourselves what's the domain and range
of a graphical user application?
The domain--that is to say, the set of legal inputs--
is basically just going to be the set of all possible GUI actions,
so mouse clicks, keyboard events, swipes, etc.
And the range is going to be possible states of the GUI application.
So now it should go without saying that the size of the domain here--
that is to say, the size of the set of all possible GUI inputs--
is really pretty gigantic.
There are a lot of possible combinations of inputs.
And so now I have a quiz question for you.
The question is what constitutes a set of good test inputs for a GUI application?
Answer a) is just use the application normally.
Answer b) is let a 4-year-old use the application for a while.
Answer c) is use some sort of a tool to inject a stream of fake GUI events--
that is to say, a stream of automatically generated keyboard events,
mouse clicks, and similar.
And answer d) is reproduce GUI inputs--that is to say, mouse clicks and such--
that crashed our previous version of our software.
So go ahead and write all of the answers that apply in the text box here.